una reunión de emergencia convocada a
petición de izquierda los miembros del
consejo de seguridad de la onu
condenaron la decisión de rusia de
reconocer la independencia de las
regiones separatistas del este de
ucrania
con ello eeuu dijo que vladimir putin
había hecho trizas los acuerdos de minsk
y desde entonces ha anunciado que
dispondrá tropas rusas en estas regiones
las llamo fuerzas de paz esto es una
tontería sabemos lo que realmente son
iguales quiere demostrar que mediante la
fuerza puede hacer una farsa de la onu
linda fama en springfield dijo que la
decisión de moscú formaba parte de su
intento de crear un pretexto para una
nueva invasión y señaló que putin quería
retroceder en el tiempo hasta 1919 otros
miembros del consejo hicieron eco de las
condenas
rusia nos ha llevado al borde al tratar
de redibujar las fronteras por la fuerza
las acciones de rusia muestran un
flagrante desprecio por el derecho
internacional
en sanar
[Música]
el enviado de rusia ante la onu subrayó
la necesidad de defender las zonas
separatistas de lo que llamó agresión
ucraniana we bought seguimos abiertos a
la diplomacia para llegar a una solución
sin embargo permitir un nuevo baño de
sangre en el donbass es algo que no
tenemos intención de hacer el
representante de china en la onu instó a
todas las partes a actuar con moderación
la crisis entre rusia y ucrania ha
puesto a beijing en la posición de
tratar de equilibrar la amistad con
moscú con su política de firme defensa
de la soberanía estatal no se adoptó
ninguna medida tras la reunión pero eeuu
dijo que el consejo había enviado un
mensaje unificado